for
e
right good evening
everybody we'll make a start on the
meeting uh welcome to cabinet for the
25th of January good to see so many
members of the council officers members
of the public here you're all very
welcome and um those people tuning in on
the
stream first of all fire alarm
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated vate the officers via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in Hy Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber please switch off and turn to
silent your mobile phones and do not
make or receive calls while this meeting
is in progress note that the meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public the meeting will also be recorded
and available later on the internet does
anyone intend to film the
meeting
no so the following members have asked
to speak under Council procedure Rule
20.1 and just for the benefit of of
those who are not familiar with how
cabinet meetings work um the members of
the committee are my myself and the
members in the front row there um other
councilors are able to speak once on any
item but it isn't a debate um this come
come across as being slightly strange if
you're used to other kinds of council
meeting um it's the way that Council
cabinets work up and down the country
and it's set out by law that it works in
this way so it's not a funny fanic
practice but it is a bit odd and if you
haven't seen it before you might find it
a bit strange the forign members have
asked to speak under Council procedure
rule 20.1
item five councelor Rogers item six
councilor warro Braidwood green Austin
Davis Cup and
Pew item eight councelor Austin item 11
councilor Austin Davidson Pew and item
12 councilor's Austin and Davis are
there any more requests from members to
speak not seeing any thank you very
much
right
uh there are no apologies because
cabinet is all here does anyone have an
interest to declare in the items of
business on the agenda this evening
councilor
wh um as I am employed by K County
Council working to support residents um
who are Autistic or with complex needs
although I do not work in relation to
highways I will be excusing myself for
the part of the shut item that refers to
the KCC Road thank
you thank you councilor white and we
will separate out the part of that item
which talks about KCC and their plans
for a road in order to facilitate
that um minutes of the previous meeting
members uh summary of recommendations
and decisions of the cabinet held on the
11th of January copy is attached to the
agenda pack I propose we take the
ministers read do I have a second up
councelor alurn is that agreed members
great thank you moving on to the first
substantive item which is item four the
draft corporate plan for 24 2024 to
28 and that's
me so the report in front of cabinet
this evening proposes a new corporate
plan which intends to set the direction
of travel for the council over the next
four years
having a clearly defined plan is
essential to support the council to work
towards achieving our longer term
aspirations for thanet and to ensure
that resources across the council are
focused on what matters most to local
people having a clear and concise
corporate plan will help us to ensure
that the community and our stakeholders
are aware of the work the council is
delivering and through our regular
reporting of our performance will have
an oversight of the progress being made
the draft plan has now been out for
public consultation for a period of 7
weeks and my thanks to everyone who took
the time to respond there is
encouragingly Broad support for the
proposed new priorities for the council
which are one to keep our district safe
and clean two to deliver the housing we
need three to protect our environment
four to create a thriving place and five
to work efficiently for you as I've said
before these are clear statements which
reflect the ongoing feedback that we
receive from the public when they tell
us that they want their streets to be
kept clean to be able to feel safe and
to have thriving towns in the district
my thanks also go to the overview and
scrutiny panel for their consideration
of the draft plan at their meeting last
week and for their
support within our 10-year Vision we
aspire to the prosperity of our
residents
increasing and as such I'd like to
propose an addition to the draft
corporate plan this is to include a
reference within our priorities which
acknowledges the work the council
carries out with our partners to address
the health inequalities which we know
exist across the district while we not
directly responsible for delivering
those Services we have a key role to
play in supporting that this activity
and I think the plan should refer to
this point with this in mind I move the
cabinet recommends the draft corporate
plan taking into account the proposed
addition for final approval at fall
Council on Thursday 8th of February do I
have a second
up I think I think councilor ke I think
councelor Keem won the race thank you uh
members any
comments okay so that will come back to
council is that agreed AG thank you move
on to the next
item item five decision for a coastal
and Beach Public spaces protection order
PSP pspo renewal to 2027 counc
Alin yeah thank you chair
um this report covers the renewal of the
beach and Coastal uh
pspo and for the um me uh for the
members of the public uh it's a public
space protection order that is that is
what it's for and this is for the period
the 1st of April 2024 to the 31st of
March
2027 an evaluation of the beach and
Coast pspo for the period the 1st of
April 2021 to the 31st of March 2024 has
been
completed it found that the majority of
beach users have followed the beach and
Coast pspo code of conduct residents uh
have a good understanding of the beach
and coast pspo and visitors have a
lesser understanding of the overall uh
pspo the council's uh Beach and Coast
team have undertaken positive
stakeholder relationships which have
helped uh spread a wider awareness and
understanding of the beach and Coast
pspo the council has seen a a decrease
in complaints over the past 3 years
breaches of pspo have also
decreased if we do not renew the pspo
our blue flag and seaside Awards may not
be renewed without the beach and Coast
pspo we shall struggle to protect our
beast and uh Beast or even Beach and
coastal areas from antisocial
behavior um I I I would add at this
point chair that um I'm extremely
grateful for the work that our staff did
uh last summer uh I think uh what's
happened over the last three years which
included the previous administration and
I'm not going to leave them out of them
out of it uh and we're continuing uh and
improving the work in in relation to
this um so um I recommend option one uh
of the report and that is that cabinet
approved the renewal of the current pspo
until the 30th of March 2027 as adopted
in accordance with the antisocial
Behavior crime and policing act uh 20 uh
2014 thank you
chair
second and speaking number 20.1 we have
Council
rers thank you leader I am concerned
that the public nuisance of visitors
parking across people's drives as they
go to the beach does not seem to be
addressed I'm aware that this problem
comes up under an enforcement officers
remit but 1.3 states that our local
communities are impacted by antisocial
Behavior currently this inconsiderate
Park in particular infuriates residents
of botony bay and King Kingsgate living
close to the beach I've read the code of
conduct so would it not be a good idea
to add a request to par considerably to
the code code of conduct book it's are
handed out and maybe an education
officer might pick this up thank
you yes thank you Council Rogers um I I
think um sorry got two oh sorry oh well
I mean so I'm I'm in Stereo people but
thank you one a do one a do
um I think what you have to take into
account here is that when it comes to
law on the highway uh if there's no
vehicle parked on a drive anybody can
park in front of that in front of that
drive uh that is not an offense and it's
not something that uh thanet District
Council uh Enforcement Officers can can
deal with uh they also couldn't really
deal with if they are blocked in on on
their drive but I I think um where I
live up on pal on Palm Bay and I quite
often walk down uh to botney Bay in the
summer uh and I've seen it I've seen
them driving on the on the on the
pavement going down and that so um we
have taken as many steps as we can by
putting up telling people not to park
down there because there isn't enough
parking don't go down there there's no
etc etc um but I I certainly happy to
take that on board and to discuss that
with uh with officers thank
you thank few members any
comments okay it's been moved and
seconded it's not very complicated
recommendation so I think we can
probably repeat to approve the renewal
of the current pspo until the 30th March
2027 as adopted in accordance with the
antisocial Behavior crime and policing
act 2014 do members agree agree thank
you we move on to item six which is the
land at Shon
Road
and I shall lead off on
this um the council completed Egyptian
traveler accommodation assessment in
2019 which forms part of the evidence
base for the fic local plan the study is
published on the council's website the
assessment considered the accommodation
needs of gypsy Travelers and traveling
show people the study identified the
need for seven permanent pitches and
five Transit pitches over the plan
period to
2031 this need is driven entirely by the
current and anticipated future needs of
families already in the area and who are
already an integral part of our
community the council has a duty to plan
for sites to meet these identified
needs Council already has a criteria
based policy in the existing adopted
local plan that allows for planning
applications to be considered and
determined and the details of this
policy are set out in the
report this is not the first time that
this cabinet has considered the need for
Gypsy and traveler s in the district on
the 16th of December 2019 cabinet
considered some potential options for a
tolerated stopping site a report was
subsequently published ahead of the
cabinet meeting on the 30th of July
2020 which assessed a number of further
sites including the site at shot and D
Road the report was deferred and not
discussed cabinet then considered a
further report its meeting on the 17th
of September 2020 when it was decided
that the issue of site allocation would
be considered as part of the local plan
review since that time in preparation
for a review of the local plan we've
held a call for sites specifically
inviting submissions of land to provide
for the need of gypsies and travelers
and the council receive no
submissions Additionally the local Plan
update continues to be delayed as a
result of a number of uncertainties
including about future housing numbers
and how they should be calculated and
about the level of protection awarded to
agricultural land through the national
planning policy
framework further work on assessing
suitable sites for Gypsy and traveler
provision was done by the conservative
Administration between 2021 and 23 2023
and I understand that cabinet members
visited shot and D road then and
identified it as a potential sight but
the council failed in a funding bid to
take matters
forward the recommendation in this
report is to undertake a public
consultation about the potential to
provide some Gypsy and traveler pitches
on the land at noton
Road the submission of a planning
application will be subject to the
outcome of this
consultation and which is in itself
subject to a further period of
consultation the consultation responses
that we reive from the process envisaged
here will be brought back to this
cabinet for a further decision which
means that they will also go to overview
and scrutiny before any planning
application is submitted
commed it's fully
recognized that the shot d Road site is
currently used as agricultural land and
the report therefore recommends that
cabinet notes that no proposals for
housing on the land could come forward
ahead of the local plan review by which
time the number of homes that the
council will have to provide by 2040 and
the level of protection provided to
agricultural land through the national
plan planning policy framework may be
clearer so her housing to be clear does
not form any part of a consideration
tonight overview and scrutiny made two
recommendations when it considered the
report which were around dealing with
the outcome of the proposed consultation
and delaying the consultation to look at
other
sites given that two different cabinets
have previously looked at a long list of
other sites twice in the last four years
and the council was also conducted a
call for sites for this use without
success this does not seem to me
appropriate in any event more than one
site is likely to be required as set out
in the
report in view of the public interest
however a mindful of the need for Trans
transparency I propose to amend
recommendation two in the report um in
line with what I've said before so that
the public and members can be clear that
the consultation responses will be
brought back for consideration by this
committee um the report also recommends
the disposal of two areas of the site to
Ken County Council to facilitate the new
route of the inner circuit major road
Network this route has itself been the
subject of a major public consultation
and is an integral part of the
district's infrastructure needs now in
order to facilitate um councilor
Whitehead's participation in this item
I'm going to take um recommendations 1
two and four and then return to
recommendation
three so what I'm moving is one to
conduct public consultation with the
gypsian traveler community and
neighboring residents about the proposal
to establish a number of gypsian
traveler pitches on land off off shuton
road the area shown in Annex 6 to the
report and following the to following
the consultation bring back to cabinet
and prior that to the overview and
scrutiny panel any proposal arising from
the consultation to submit an
application for outlying planning
permission for the provision of gypsy
and traveler pitches on the land
Mark 1A in Annex 5 and four to note that
proposals for the provision of housing
on The Wider shut and D Road Site could
only be considered following the
assessment of all land submitted to the
council as part of the call for sites
and the completion of the current review
of the thanet local plan do I have a
second for that please councilor Yates
um and before we go to 20.1 and I
appreciate there are a number of members
who wish to speak on it um I think it's
right that councilor Whitehead who is
our housing portfolio member um gives
her take on this thank
you thank you
leader as previously mentioned I will
only be speaking on the part of this
item that refers to the consultation
relating to
Shelton I will not be present for
discussion of the latter part of this
item as I work to support autistic
residents and residents with complex
needs within Kent County Council and
although the latter part of this item is
unrelated to my KCC role as it involves
Cas EC I will excuse myself after the
discussion relating to the
consultation tonight we are asked to
make a decision on one thing and one
thing only relating to this item whether
to have a consultation on the potential
provision of a traveler site on a
previously and comprehensively assessed
site at shot
andan we are not being asked to provide
a site we are not being asked to give
permission for a
site we are being asked to allow
residents to formally give their opinion
on the possibility of providing a
site that is quite literally all we are
that we are being asked to do and I am
never ever going to oppose residents
being involved in decisions that should
involve
them I am I believe known for being very
open and very
communicative I'm not known in this
chamber for being particularly partisan
mainly because I joined politics from a
background of disliking conventional
politics I find oppositional politics to
be destructive as it focuses not on what
we need to do but on individual and
Collective political ambition and it
places facts and needs far behind
political ambition and
realities I will not conduct myself in
such a way and although I am far from
perfect I will always be factual and I
will do my best to be
comprehensive tonight we are discussing
a consultation on a site which has been
assessed against National planning
conditions and
requirements this site was also ranked
as the best available site under the
previous
administration and I know that they will
have followed exactly the same planning
requirements that we would consider
now within planning requirements are
prescriptive and do not link to
political will or influence in terms of
interpretation and bluntly there are
very good reasons that they shouldn't as
planning should be a measured and
apolitical process in order to produce
un biased and fair
results residents should know that
planning considerations link to clear
guidance and that planning decisions are
not made on a political
basis the evidence that this is the case
is documented over the past years with
several administrations assessing this
site as the best available site to meet
planning needs with no political
difference in that
assessment as such divisive Nar
narratives are
unnecessary although I accept that
General politics itics will inevitably
produce this and has produced
this what is before us is a decision to
consult nothing more and nothing
less I talk probably too much in many
cases but it is because I want people to
be well informed and to understand this
is why I am as responsive as I am and as
willing as I am to face into discussions
and decisions that can be challenging as
I do not believe that anything is solved
by not facing fa in into essential
issues the reality of local government
is that all administrations face the
same challenges and in this case came to
the same conclusion when trying to
provide for illegal and moral
duty the only difference is that I am
now speaking about the entire process
and I'm very willing to have this
discussion however hard and acknowledge
not only the need we have legally and
morally to provide sites but also the
need all residents have to discuss
Express concerns be heard and understand
what is being
proposed the way to do that effectively
is to
consult our need to plan for traveler
sites is not going to go away and has to
be explored and addressed and I will not
continually push back people's needs to
have a
home every home near this proposed site
was once built an agricultural land and
the traveling community in this area has
long-standing links and history with
agriculture we cannot have a discussion
regarding the importance of Agriculture
on a site that even if used in this way
could still offer agricultural tencies
in Parts while simultaneously denying
the importance of providing for those
who are culturally and historically
linked to agriculture in this area
especially when no formal provision has
been made for them before this
point I have seen and responded to many
comments online stating that people are
not being heard or listened to when in
fact the entire point of a consultation
is to listen listen and people cannot be
formally heard without
it the two realities that we Face here
are not mutually
exclusive people have a right to a home
and people have a right to be
heard how we provide a site and where
and what we need to consider and take
into account is all part of the
consultation
process and that process is one that
should be and remain clear and calm as
that is what is deserved by an issue
this significant
we are planning longterm for how our
community works and how we support all
of our
residents there is nothing more
important than that and ensuring that
all residents and all communities are
consulted is the very first part of
doing this thank
you thank you councelor Whitehead and I
I remind the members speaking under 20.1
of the rules which basically entitle you
to speak once um ask questions make
statements say whatever you want to say
um but it isn't a debate and I don't
think it will be helpful if we try and
turn it into a
debate uh councelor
Warr thank you leader good evening
cabinet good evening members and good
evening members of the
public um I've I've recently been
speaking to local tenant farmer Jonathan
tap whose family has been farming in
Garing for
Generations farmer tap is devastated by
the news that is being kicked off of his
farmland and I want to know
why this Green Field grade agriculture
land we were talking about agriculture
land earlier but the difference is this
is grade one the said agricultural land
wasn't why is this green land being
singled out when branfield sites such as
the former hoverport site in Cliff end
were not
considered and uh also I'd like to seek
Clarity for recommendation for that once
adopted the public consultation will
only be done once the assessment of all
land submitted has been completed thank
you for allowing me to speak
later thank you councelor War I'll bring
um councelor Whitehead in um as you've
referred publicly to the hoverport site
and you've made a false claim on your
Facebook page which I've told you is a
false claim that I have personally
intervened to reject the hoverport site
let's be clear that the hoverport site
is on a long list of sites which was
considered by the council in
201920 and by the conservative
Administration um which left office um
last year and that nobody has ever put
forward the hover hoverport site as a
viable site it has never been ranked and
in fact I think in the initial uh
ranking it was bottom of a list of about
14 sites um there's certainly been no
discussion under this Administration um
in the last year about the hoverport
site whatsoever other than that prompted
by you councelor
whad thank you leader and thank you
councilor
waro in relation to Mr tap um I'm not
sure if he's present but I don't
particularly like speaking about people
when they're not here I have been also
speaking to Mr tap um have invited him
to a meeting to
discuss both the site and the future of
the site um as he was also invited to
previously when the site was put forward
he has accepted that meeting I am very
very happy to have that
and that meeting as it could have done
previously will also cover discussions
of long leases of part of the site and
short-term leases of other parts
the reason for the termination of the
lease uh links to the fact that all of
this land is linked under the current
lease I can't discuss the KCC related
part but clearly there are difficulties
around the separation of that which
require a new lease but we are going to
have discussions with Mr tap and as I
said I've welcomed that and invited him
to meet several times thank
you
councilor
bra thank you
chair the local plan the bedrock in
which all planning decisions are made
within this Council contains policy
ho20 this policy P specifically States
gives guidance for site and
accommodations for Gypsy and traveling
communities and gives Four Points to
consider when identifying suitable land
my question is this why has the this
particular plot of land has shut and
Dame Road been identified when it
doesn't adhere to point three which
states in our quote not have been a
flood risk and point four which states
in our quote will not have an
unacceptably detrimental impact on local
Environmental Quality including green
wedges or sensitive landscape areas
thank
you Mr poter do you want to comment on
that
please
uh thank you leader um well just a
couple of points really the first one is
to say that um if um and when any
planning application is considered um
and it would be have to be considered by
the planning committee um because of the
council's interest in this site um the
these would be the criteria that the
planning committee would use U to make a
judgment about the suitability of any
proposal um in terms of the specifics um
the site is not within the identified
flood risk areas within the district um
so I'm not quite sure um where that
information is that it is a flood risk
area um clearly I'd be happy to have a
further conversation about that but it's
not it's not within the identified flood
risk areas in in the local plan um and
uh on the third Point um well it's it's
not within the green wedges or the
identified area of sensitive landscape
um but clearly there would be a judgment
made by both the planning officers and
the planning committee uh about whether
any proposal had a detrimental
impact thank you um counc
green yeah thank you
um I thought I would try to reflect what
over View and scrutiny thought of this
in the absence of Council of
fellows uh feels in a far better
place now than be than being here
um he's on holiday
uh I think the
committee thought about fairness and
transparency and I think 2third of uh of
this proposal for the road and and for
housing we were in agreement in
agreement with what's being
proposed and the the the housing land
being considered along with all other uh
bits of housing
land uh seemed to me a fair way of or
seem to us a fair way of dealing with
these
matters I accept that that this land and
land in thanet has been looked at
before but the criteria used and the uh
and the the results of of those looks
wasn't in isn't in the paper that that
that was brought forward and I don't
think we can expect
residents to know what
happened months months and years ago and
how how uh this
land uh has been ch
selected for this for this special
treatment so the so the committee felt
that rather than just consult on this
piece of
land Council should should collect
together the
evidence that most of which uh has been
collected before but there may still be
um New pieces of land I if a new call
was made
um and and then transparently judge all
those pieces of land against the
criteria that needs to be used we
recognized that the council doesn't need
to provide land for travelers if only to
comply with government
regulations but from the point of view
of the residents they want to see and
they want to see now that this land is
being treated along with all other that
could possibly be
used thank you councelor green um I
can't speak to the transparency or
otherwise of of of the discussions that
the conservative administration had I
know that there was um a scrutiny
Committee in the
2019 20 Council panel uh report which
went to overview and scrutiny and then
went to council at cabinet has as I
outlined in my introduction um there's
quite a lot of information in the public
domain about that I think the other
challenge is that um we we need more
than one site that's what we're
requested to provide we're not we're not
suggesting um that we would be able to
deliver all the provision that's needed
on this site I mean we could suggest
that but we're not suggesting that we
think that uh a better approach is to
have a number of different sites um and
that those sites are
smaller um so the reality is that we are
going to have to look for other sites as
well over time so I think given taking
that into account and given the amount
of work that's been done previously at
looking at other sites in the
district I'm not sure that going off and
looking at other places is going to make
any difference to the proposal to bring
this forward for consultation but we
need to see what the outcome of the
consultation is we want to hear from the
local residents we also want to hear
from the Gypsy and traveler Community
about what their needs are and what they
think about it um because they have a
voice too um and when we've got that
information we will bring it back and
discuss it further and I think that's
where we are but I I understand your
point about transparency but I would say
there's a lot of information in the
public domain already um and the thing
about land is it doesn't move does it um
the sites are what are what they are
some of them will get developed and and
will move on to different uses but um
generally speaking the long list of
sites is pretty informative I don't know
if anyone wants to add anything to
that you want to
say could I just say something on that
would it be possible to bring that
information that already exists forward
and publish it so that residents can see
it well as I say that the information
relating to um the
2019 20 discussions is all in the public
domain it's on the council's website I'm
sure we can make it more available um
I'd have to have a conversation with
officers about work done by the
conservative administration because I
don't know what the propriety of that is
um and they can no doubt speak to
themselves and probably will M Mr
Porter well I don't think I've got very
much to add to that but just to confirm
um that the previous evaluations that
were done in 2019 are available on the
council's website um they might not be
the easiest to find because they're
within the agenda paper and minutes of
the cabinet at the time and the overview
and scrutiny panel at the time um I
think what we can um undertake to do is
make those um uh more e easy to find on
the website so that if anybody wants to
look at those they don't have to you
know search around they can find them
more easily uh so I'm sure we can do
that uh Moving On cast
Rustin thank you leader um as a green
party counselor I inevitably regret any
uh plans to do anything with uh
agricultural land other than grow food
on it but on the other hand as a
counselor who's been working with
traveler families for some years now
having had a group of families um
literally dumped in my ward um I have
become acutely aware of the need for
these sites and the fact that we have
let the traveler community in than it
down by not providing sites so I very
much welcome the consultation but I
think the point needs to be made as we
tried to make at scrutiny uh the other
week that this is just the beginning of
a process and it's about listening to
what everybody wants to say the uh
tenant Farmers the residents the members
of The Traveler community and I think
it's very important that we listen to
all those views and take them on board
um and I think the there has been a lot
of um
unhelpful messaging on social media to
suggest that this is a done deal I think
it's perfectly clear that it's a not a
done deal and I very much welcome
cabinet's transparency on this and I'm
very pleased to hear Mr Porter say that
he will put the criteria into a place on
the website where it's easy to find
because I think we do have a rather a
tendency both as counselors and officers
to say ah it's on the website and it
actually turns out to be ins obscure
Corner that you couldn't possibly find
unless you happen to have been there at
that particular meeting 5 years ago so
um so thank you very much for that and
um I look forward to participating in
the consultation thank
you thank you Council Austin I don't
think that that requires any comment
from me
um councelor
Davis thank you later
um it's an interesting scenario here
because we do have a liability and a
responsibility obviously however not
just to The Travelers but to the
community at large um and uh you know
for the best interests of everybody
having been elected on a on a mandate of
protecting agricultural land I think
it's fair to say where you know my heart
lies on this uh and that has no respon
no no relationship to to to any
individual however um there seem to be a
few sort of anomalies here I did ask
last last week I believe it was um about
the total acreage required to
accommodate um with permanent and
temporary pitches I don't know if we
have that figure yet but I have to
observe that if we don't know that
acreage yet then I don't see how we can
consult or a decision can be taken
because we need to know what is required
otherwise we're just scratching the
fingernail and not solving the problem
problem um which it clearly is a problem
if this is the only site that's been
identified uh to date I don't see how we
can provide several smaller sites uh
because land doesn't just magic out of
nowhere obviously so I think part of
this discussion needs to be what is
actually necessary and needed um I would
imp I would implore the council to look
for non-g Greenfield sites to
accommodate not just the Travelers but
as as much development as possible
[Music]
um and we need to protect our our
highgrade agricultural land in addition
it may not legally defi be defined as
green wedge but it does provide a green
break between the uh urbanizations of
Garing and shenan and to conate between
them totally changes the you know the
character of the area and everything so
it does have implications in terms of of
of people lives on a day-to-day basis
thank
you thank you councelor Davis um I take
the point that that the size of land
allocated is is relevant to the
consultation I'm not sure given that we
know it's rough proportions in relation
to the overall site is necessary for us
to make a decision to carry out a
consultation but I'll ask Mr pter if
he's able to
elaborate um well I think the the key
thing the answer that I gave at the um
over and scrutiny panel um is that the
the the AC the the site area requirement
very much depends on the number of
pitches that um would come forward in
any proposal and that is very much
subject to uh consultation uh and um
neighboring residents and the Gypsy and
traveler Community will have a view
about the number of pitches that would
um potentially be um provided in the
same place uh and I know that is
particularly uh an issue for the the
traveling Community themselves about um
how um Family U family sites work um on
and the appropriate scale um so I can't
I don't think we can answer the question
directly at this stage uh until we've
had those conversations about uh um what
any proposal might look like in terms of
the number of pitches we do have
information
um and it's available nationally there's
National guidance about um this the area
for individual pitches um which I'd be
more than happy to share with you um
what I can say is that AP pitch um in
that guidance uh represents enough land
for two Caravans and two vehicles um and
um obviously um that multiplies up if
it's if it's a number of
pitches thank thank you uh councelor
cup thank you leader um I am cautious
not to repeat what's already been said
but I just wanted to uh give my
interpretation of uh the overview scru
the uh panel and the recommendation that
was brought forward because consultation
absolutely is is right and uh it needs
to be done to ensure that the public are
um not just notified but also so their
voices are heard but I I would also
argue that we as counselors are here to
represent our residents and we listen to
our residents we talk to our residents
and they give us a Viewpoint and on that
overview and scrutiny panel we put
forward a recommendation to ensure that
there was a hold on um Consulting on
just one site and rather consult on
multiple sites one saving time for the
council and possibly money but also
showing that there is uh other
possibilities available and I think
what's also important is that
the overview and scrutiny panel was a
cross-party um agreement there was uh it
was proposed by councelor green and
seconded by myself and every member on
that committee agreed with that
recommendation and I think overview and
scrutiny is incredibly important to
ensure that um all the council was being
heard when items are being brought
forward and um are being either agreed
by cabinet um and it's not very often
that you get recommendations brought
forward by overview and scrutiny on
things but as we've seen by um the the
the public reaction to this it was right
the overview and scrutiny put forward
recommendations and my fear is if the
cabinet tonight don't take forward the
recommendation that overview scrutiny
put forward how can the public seem to
trust the cabinet if they aren't even
listening to the overview scrutiny
committee thank you
chair
well thank you councelor cup I mean in
terms of adding to what I said earlier
um the reality is that cabinet is the
decision-making body and overview and
scrutiny is an advisory body if if
cabinet was bound to accept every
recommendation from overview and
scrutiny and there'd be no point in
having cabinet we would simply send
decisions to overview and scrutiny and
they could decide and that's not how the
system works and you know it's not how
the system works um this Administration
has taken the decision to put all key
decisions in front of overview and
scrutiny before we make a decision that
hasn't been the case necessarily in the
past I think it's a good approach um I
welcome the discussion I think there
have been some very useful discussions
on a number of matters at overview and
scrutiny which has informed the cabinet
cabinet decisions that have been taken I
think it's a better way of making policy
um I think in this case I would argue
that
the recommendations of overview and
scrutiny are somewhat confusing in that
it appears to propose conduct agree with
conducting a public consultation but
basically saying not making a decision
arising from that
consultation um and not actually doing
the consultation
now but going off and carrying out
another process of assessing sites so I
don't think that the conclusions as
presented to me and unfortunately due to
the fact the streaming service wasn't
work wasn't working I couldn't watch it
and I would have watched it cuz I wanted
to hear what members and what members
had to say I don't think that those
recommendations are particularly
coherent as presented to me and that may
or may not be um what how the meeting
expressed itself but we understand that
this is a a matter of um significant
public interest particularly in the
Garing area um and we will continue to
engage and listen to what people are
saying to
us uh councilor pew
thank you chair um I'll try and be brief
um there's a lot to go through and I
don't want to uh rehash over what's
already been discussed uh by everyone um
but I do think I've got a few questions
to ask on this uh shot and D Road Site
um and then there's a few points of
clarification I'd like to make
particularly to do with the previous
conservative Administration and what we
potentially did or did not do my thir
question is particularly in relation to
this site is that
cabinet is deciding tonight to consult
on one site and one site only and I
agree with the recommendations that
overie scrutiny um well put forward um
in that actually I think it would be
better to consult on a variety of sites
I know that there are more sites that uh
we as the previous administration looked
at cabinet toward a variety of sites
this site being one of them um in the
last
Administration but more importantly I
think it's it's important that the
council if really care about
consultation on what residents think and
I concede that yes we do need to have a
a legal site because otherwise we'll
continue to be victim of illegal
encampments and the issues that come
with that and um particularly for for
nearby residents when Travelers kind of
pull up in car Parks or in parks and and
our green spaces and stuff like that but
I do think it's important if we really
care about consultation that we consult
on all potential possible sites
particularly if as is being admitted
tonight is that even if this site does
come forward and it's created a traveler
site that won't be enough to meet local
needs secondly um and again particularly
just on the consultation for this site
um I'd like confirmation on what the
council will do if residents respond to
the consultation that they don't want
this site to be there and that they
don't think it's suitable um what will
TDC as an authority decide to do will we
then decide to just ignore what
residents have said because I think
consultation the word consultation has
probably yes thank you I the word
consultation has probably been used more
not just by me but by everyone that's
spoken tonight it's consultation
consultation consultation consultation
this is a consultation well that's all
very well and fine but if residents
respond that they don't agree with this
and they don't want it and we then as a
council decide to ignore them and say
actually we know best and this needs to
be a gypsy and traveler site then really
I question the point of us holding the
consultation if we're not going to then
take into consideration and act on
residents views councelor cup is
incredibly uh right and I don't I don't
normally admit I agree with councelor
cup so often but you know we've been
elected I know it does make a change uh
but we've been elected to represent our
residents um and to represent them as
best we can and I appreciate that we
need to make difficult decisions
sometimes but to hold a consultation
that's only a consultation in name only
uh for the sake of ensuring that we then
have a a legal uh Gypsy and traveler
site
um I think is quite a pointless
task now to provide Clarity on what the
previous conservative Administration may
or may not have done um and I feel that
it's probably been confirmed
tonight my suspicions of what had been
said um on social media by other elected
counselors that aren't conservatives
over the last few
weeks that this Administration is Keen
to blame the conservative Administration
for why this site is being brought
forward why this consultation is started
um and why we're clearly or this
Administration is clearly in the mess
that they
are that's not the case it's not true
the conservative cabinet tour a variety
of sites this was one of them I believe
last year but the years are kind of
flying by quite quickly now so I do
apologize if I've got that wrong by a
year or two there were rev thank you
Council bord has confirmed it was last
year so I'm not going mad we've t a
variety of sites this was one of those
sites before that there was a working
group I believe that was set up under
the previous labor Administration to
decide or to look at and examine a much
wider uh number of sites now I know uh
Council War has referenced the hoverport
site and uh down at pegwell I'll be
honest and I'm not trying to add wood to
the fire or Stoke any tensions but I do
not remember at any time when the
previous administration considered any
options ever seeing the port on a list
now I'm not trying to blame anyone for
that but when that was then mentioned
that was complete news to me so I'm not
questioning whether it's suitable or not
or if we should go for that but I can
say categorically I've never seen it
mentioned on any list of potential
sites but when it comes to us touring
the sites no decision was made by the
previous concertive administration about
what site would be suitable or what site
should be pursued first
if it had have been I'd be very
uncomfortable and I know it's easy for
me to say this now I'm in opposition but
I'd be very uncomfortable with putting a
consultation forward for only one site
and I think again as has been admitted
tonight if we do need more than one site
and we know that we need more than one
site and that this site won't be enough
then surely we should be Consulting on
enough sites to cover that need and I
think the residents deserve that because
from what we've seen of the local
reaction uh in Garing is that this of
course is potent and I know it's hard
for us to break news to Residents that
we're going to launch consultation this
has obviously been unwelcome news and it
has blindsided residents and of course
if we're now going to try and identify
other sites and put forward other
consultations we're going to have the
same problem again whereas I think that
actually it would be better to do it all
in one go let's consult on multiple
sites and see what residents say thank
you yeah thank you Council Pew
um I
think what I'd like to make clear this
isn't about blaming the previous
administration but I think it's also
fair that the public know that this
issue has been explored by the previous
cabinet that there is a list of sites
and that shot andan was ranked highly in
that
list and I don't think you know it
wouldn't be appropriate for us to
conceal that and at the same time you
know you must speak for yourself for
what your Administration did
um the reason that shot andan is coming
forward is because it's in the council's
ownership there are challenges with
other sites which were um ranked as I
understand it by the conservative
cabinet um some of them are not in the
council's ownership some of them um
perhaps been designated for other
things so it's not simply a question of
listing out all the available sites and
asking the public to comment on them
because there's absolutely no point in
asking the public to comment on a site
that the council doesn't control and
can't get access to um I will correct
you um the document that I have seen
which ranks nine sites I think lists
another eight sites which were not
considered for ranking because they're
not possibly
viable um I don't actually have any
strong opinion about the hover Port um
it's a bit of a myth that I live next to
it I don't I don't and you can look that
up on the map um the hoverport site
unfortunately um is clearly a flood risk
and it's next next to a tri SII and it's
also as I understand it
contaminated um the council doesn't have
a plan for that site um I wish we did
because it's a big piece of recovered
land which um is going to waste it's
very difficult to know what can be done
with it um but it is on the list of
sites that were considered in 2019 1920
it was ranked bottom of all the sites by
the by the scoring through objective
criteria and it is on the list of sites
that I've seen that was put before the
conservative cabinet now we can consider
that document outside the meeting if you
like counil few I'm I'm not proposing to
publish that document don't think it's
for me to publish it but um I'll take
advice on that um in terms of in terms
of listening to a consultation I think
it's important to understand that a
consultation is not a referendum
planning process incorporates
consultation um the fact that hundreds
of people may object to a particular
planning
application doesn't mean that that
planning application can't be approved
if it meets the planning criteria and
the person who own the owns the site
wants to do it you don't get a vote over
your neighbor's property the real
purpose of a consultation is to hear the
Practical reasons why something should
not go ahead so I do understand the
concern concern of residents in Garing
in particular about these proposals what
you need to tell us is why you object
what the impacts would be on you and
then we can take them into account
simply telling us you don't want it
wouldn't really suffice and the same
goes for The Travelers we need to ask
them what do they want how will it work
for them is it the right place for them
that's what the consultation is um I'm
certainly not prejudging what the
council would do next we would look at
the results of the consultation we will
publish the results of the consultation
and we will consider it in at least two
public forums so you you have that
Assurance this is a discussion we want
to hear from you we want to hear from
The
Travelers and I know it's a difficult
subject and you know I pay tribute to
members for the reasoned and and
measured way in which they've conducted
it this they conducted discussions this
evening and thank the public for their
um
I than P the public for listening
because it's important and it's
important that we listen to you but it's
a difficult issue we understand it's a
difficult issue but we can't keep going
around in circles we have to come to
some conclusion that's where we're
trying to go councelor
Whitehead thank you leader
um I'd just like to come back on the
blame point because I want to be very
very clear and I think I have been
clear
and I think I have been very clear
online that this is not about blame but
rather it is about consensus and whether
people want to admit consensus is
something else entirely but to go back
to the first part of my speech the
reality of local government is that all
administrations face the same challenges
and in this case came to the same
conclusion when trying to provide for a
legal and moral duty the only difference
is that I am speaking about the entire
process and I'm very willing to have the
discussion however hard and acknowledge
not only the need we have legally and
morally to provide sites but also the
need all residents have to discuss
Express concerns be heard and understand
what is being
proposed in context of what did happen
the sites were ranked between April 22
and March 23 with site visits as you
said on the 29th of
April and I would like to make the point
that a funding bid was submitted
for the shot and D site during your
Administration but wasn't successful
that indicates that you thought that
that site had priority or it would not
have been
submitted so I very much take issue with
being painted as being oppositional in
this sense when actually I'm simply
being truthful about processes that
weren't made
visible I am going to be visible I am
more than happy as you will have seen on
social media to talk about all of
this but I don't think it's anything
that I should be condemned for I think
being open is important and I think
being truthful is important thank
you thank you counc
wad ccor
Yates thank you uh leader um just I
think it might be useful uh potentially
if I can ask the officers just to
explain the next steps of the process um
so the
consultation uh We've amended tonight so
it will come back here to the cabinet do
we have any idea of
timeline how long the consultation will
take and when we could expect that
cabinet meeting uh back here to be as I
think that'll be useful information to
share uh today if we can thanks yeah Mr
Pauls we haven't um discussed the
specific timeline for any consultation I
I think that's the next step um clearly
we would need to um provide sufficient
time for people to understand what's uh
being discussed and um consider their
View and submit any comments that want
to be um they would like us to consider
um we need to uh provide time in that
timeline for officers to um um um review
the review the comments that come back
and Report those comments
back through the overview and scity
panel and back to Cabinet um I'm a bit
reluctant to give a definite time scale
now um because we haven't discussed that
um roughly roughly I mean we could
probably do that within a 3mon period I
would have thought uh to to give
everybody proper time to participate in
that okay I mean I think it's important
also to be to be clear that even if the
consultation came back and said it's a
fantastic idea and cabinet moved ahead
um and asked officers to submit a
planning application the planning
process itself takes time and at the end
of the planning process there still
isn't any funding on the table so we
haven't identified how the how this
project would be funded if it was taken
forward what we do think is that we'd be
more likely to get the funding if there
was actually a site that had planning
consent I think that was possibly the
challenge that um officers faced
before right members um it's been moved
and seconded that and I will repeat the
the recommendations that we're voting
for voting on to conduct public
consultation with the gypsian traveler
community and neighboring residents
about the proposal to establish a number
of gypsian traveler pitches on land off
of shotan Road following the
consultation to bring back to cabinet
and prior that prior to that to the
overview and screw scrutiny panel any
proposal arising to submit an
application for outlying planning
permission for the provision of gypsian
travelites on the land mark
1A and to note that proposals for the
provision of housing on The Wider shutan
Road Site can only be considered
following the assessment of all land
submitted to the council as part of the
call for sites and the completion of the
current review of the fet local plan is
that
agreements thank you I invite councilor
head to
leave but don't go too
far uh members uh recommendation three
is to dispose of part of the land at
shom Road the areas marked as 1B and 2B
on Annex 5 to Kent County Council for
the proposed major Road Network inner
circuit improvements and a linked
sustainable drainage scheme and I so
propose so seconder please councelor
Yates members do you wish to speak on
this thank you is that agreed agreed
thank
you yeah Council whad she shut the door
can we get Council whad thank
you um members of the public you're
entirely welcome to stay for the rest of
the meeting if you wish to leave we
won't take offense that's entirely up to
you we do have a number of long list of
items to
consider and can I thank you for your
attendance and courtesy this
evening
we move on to item seven which is the
temporary staff contract and that's
councelor Alban it's me all the best
stuff um thank you chair um the uh
current contract to provide the council
with temporary staff is due to expire on
the 14th of April
2024 it is a three-year contract with a
one-year extension option this extension
was exercised in April of last
year temporary or agency staff are
required to replace staff that are off
through annual leave or
sickness often at short notice and also
to cover seasonal variations such as
additional Beach cleaning in the summer
and also for uh the emptying of our uh
massive amount of waste that we have on
on the sea
fronts um the current annual spend of
this contract is uh approximately 1.3
million per anom 80% of this cost is
attributed to the cleansing
service it should be noted that this is
a c down contract with no obligation to
spend the projected 1.3
million the contract has not been
awarded this decision is requesting
approval for it to be procured via an
agreed framework and as part of this
process a full review will be conducted
into the use of agency staff within
thanate District Council I therefore
propose uh chair option three of the
report which is as follows further
competition under a framework of a
three-year contract with a 12-month
extension of option with a value of
approximately 1.3 million perom this
option is resource intensive and rates
may not be as favorable when compared
across manage service providers procured
under the framework that's the
recommendation thank you chair thank you
councelor Al D second councelor
Duckworth any discussion
members is that agreed agreed thank you
moveing on to item eight please and
charges Council y
thank you
leader fees and charges were originally
presented cabinet on October 2023 as
part of the main budget report in order
to support the 2425 budget setting
process and was sub subsequently taken
to overview and scrutiny panel earlier
this month work undertaken looked to
ensure that charges would remain
competitive and the income budget
expectations were real were realistic
allowing us to manage existing
shortfalls of actual income against
budget
I made overview and scrutiny aware of
the fundamental changes through our
assumption around fees and charges these
being a review of our fee increase and
where possible bringing these to nearer
5% from the 8% as a result the budget
for 2425 now includes the allocation of
116,000 to help facilitate this the
revised Annex of this report being the
detailed schedule was not available for
the overun scrutiny meeting and I agreed
it would be brought to cabin at the end
of January for consideration the main
changes relate to the parking bin
replacement Garden waste and the
crematorium fees at overview and
scrutiny there were comments made about
Community event charges and I can
confirm that as per the annex
application fees for community events
together with the day rate costs for
Community charity and Commercial events
have been frozen so there is no increase
in these Community event costs however
given the difficulty splitting out
parking charges for events from wider
parking fees and charges the suspension
of parking Bay charges for events cannot
be frozen for these for community events
um I move the recommendations in the
report this being the cabinet consider
the fees and charges as set out and
agrees to make the recommendations to
council for
approval thank you counc for a change
councelor Al
seconded almost got in before the
recommendation for motion was made okay
councelor Austin under 20.1 please thank
you leader and thank you councelor Yates
and and um first of all congratulations
on managing to uh establish this in a in
a way that works with the uh uh with the
uh increase um in the cost of living Etc
um we have a couple of concerns or
questions and some of this is obviously
going to go into the parking review uh
we know that traders in Ramsgate in
particular are very concerned about
increased parking charges and we don't
seem to have a facility in our town for
uh half an hour's free parking in the
way that some other towns in thanit do
and we'd really like to see something
like that built into the parking review
so that everybody has space where people
can uh pop in quickly to town and buy a
loaf of bread or whatever um and um the
our other area our other area that we
would like to uh point out yes or walk
indeed where our towns safe to do so
um the other thing that we have
mentioned I think already um in
discussion with the with the leader and
yourselves is we'd like to see if if our
top priority and the top priority
identified by our residents is clean and
Safe Streets we'd like to see them safer
in terms of parking but we'd also like
to see them safe uh cleaner in terms of
litter and we'd like to see much higher
penalties as are allowed by government
for for uh littering for fly tipping for
graffiti and for fly posting which as we
pointed out to the leader the main
culprit in Ramsgate is Dreamland so we'd
like to see them find substantially for
covering all our public buildings and
spaces with their their posters um we
don't quite understand why we haven't
gone for higher uh charges fixed penalty
charges on some of those areas which
would make We Believe unappreciable
deterrent effect um for people who are
seeking to blight our environment thank
you thank you Council Austin do you want
to reply to that Council y I think a lot
of it is comes under the park interview
certainly the first part yeah um so
thank you councelor Austin um so the
half an hour free parking yeah that's uh
that'll fall under the parking review I
don't know the timelines of that but I
think some we can do you know we I'll
revert uh to uh uh uh an officer for the
timelines for that thank you it was a
name I've
forgotten
apologies thank you counselor um so the
uh the yeah the um consultation period
for the parking strategy um the first
engagement uh session is next week so
yeah it starts next week for uh elected
members and then there are further
sessions uh I think first week of or
second week of February um public
engagement sessions so um I haven't got
the date of the end of the uh engagement
sessions to to hand but it certainly
starts next
week um and just coming back on uh
question of findes so that's one of the
first questions I asked when I got
involved in fees and charges um if you
go through the spreadsheet there's a
blue column
um which separates out discretionary and
statutary charges so a lot of the fines
that we offer unfortunately statutary
but if there are specific ones which are
discretionary which um uh you think
should be higher then I'm happy to have
those conversations we can always amend
fees and charges in year uh if we do get
agreement but it wouldn't be typical um
but yeah if there are specific points on
that but from my understanding a lot of
them ass set by government and we do
charge the maximum
thanks
um yeah thanks Council y I mean I'm sure
officers will be happy to have a word
with Dreamland if they are particularly
causing a problem with fly posting I
think some one of the challenges around
some of the other offenses that um
Council referred to is enforcing them
it's quite difficult to enforce against
people dropping litter because you've
got to find them doing it and you've got
to have people out there to do it and I
sometimes think that people who Advocate
this would not actually like the level
of surveillance that would be necessary
to for the fines to act as an effective
deterrent um but I do understand um we
all understand uh the problem and uh you
know my particular beef I'm afraid is um
graffiti and driving around Ramsgate
almost every item of public
infrastructure signs Ro M boxes BT boxes
um appears to be tagged and we intend to
get to grips with that through the
budget process or certainly to make a
difference and that's a very much part
of our plan
um members it's been moved and seconded
to um recommend the fees and charges as
set out to council does anybody else
want to say anything in that case is
that agreed agre thank you we move on to
item nine which is the East Kent
Services transm transition program
business case for approval which is
Council Yates thank you leader um
cabinet will note from the report that
Civic has provided Revenue benefits and
customer services functions to canter
over and thanet Council as a shared
service since 2018 civa have now
indicated the intention to cease
providing such Services after the expiry
of the current contract in January
2025 cabinet is being asked to agree in
principle that in the F that in in
Future these Services be provided by way
of aatco the detailed uh report sets out
the business case however cabinet is
being asked to agree that a further
business plan be brought back to cabinet
for approval once details including
details as such as the share
Arrangements are known therefore it's
recommended that cabinet one note that
the contracts between East Kent shared
services and Civic limited for the
delivery of the revenue benefits and
customer services will terminate in
March 2025 two note the content of the
service transition case says Annex one
of the report and agreeing principle to
the formation of a joint local Authority
Trading Company together with canterbary
and DOA for the delivery of the services
referred to in uh point1 above and three
agree that a further report will be
presented to cabinet for approval with
within four months together with a
detailed business plan for the proposed
company a draft shareholder agreement
and proposed articles of Association
thank
you thank you councelor Yates is there a
second councelor
Duckworth members any
comments okay I'd like to thank Miss
Chan for her for her work in in putting
together the business case that's
appreciated um I don't think you're
going to get asked any
questions thank you for coming um
members is that agreed agreed thank you
uh item 10 the purchase of seven Homes
at Northwood roow broadstairs for
affordable rent councilor
whad thank you
leader we have a duty to not only look
after those residents who are already
within the protection afforded by a
council tency but also expand this care
to those who are currently within
insecure and unaffordable private
tencies our new acquisition strategy
which has provided for the acquisition
of 123 homes in 5 months up from an
average annual delivery of 18 homes per
year over the last 10 years is a perfect
example of how using our HRA and
thinking creatively around our abilities
can produce outstanding outcomes for
residents with this purchase we are not
only providing a balanced mix of much
needed homes including three bed houses
but we are also providing them in St
Peters Ward which as with some of our
previous Acquisitions is a difficult
area to access in terms of affordable
Tendencies using our new strategy and
working consciously to support all of
our residents across housing sectors has
produced an approach that is producing
genuinely affordable homes across planet
and again I recommend Miss Jackson and
her officers wholeheartedly for the
level of work that has gone into and
continues to go into this project I move
the
recommendations thank you councelor w do
you have a second councelor
Yates any comments members
okay well I would just say um how
encouraging it is to see um still more
new affordable homes coming in front of
this committee um and I'm would say long
may that
continue members is that agreed thank
you we move on to item 11 which is the
Ramsgate regeneration program which is
me
so the council has secured 22.5 million
of government funding for regeneration
projects in Ramsgate this includes both
the future High streets fund at 2.7
million and the Ramsgate leveling up
fund at 19.8 million along with mgate
regeneration funds on which we'll be
reporting next month these programs were
part of a complex array of central
government grants with different time
scales and Reporting requirements the
government inv invited the council to
participate in its simplification
Pathfinder pilot with the aim of
simplifying project approval and
Reporting arrangements and setting a
more realistic time scale for project
delivery of March
2026 should probably say that's the back
back back stop date we're not proposing
that we won't be delivering any projects
until then this was an opportunity to
reset the program and on the 21st of
September 2023 cabinet approved a new
investment plan setting out the updated
program which has subsequently been
approved by government the program in
Ramsgate focuses on projects that
provide creative workspace improve the
public realm and connectivity between
the harbor and the town improve the port
and harbor itself and create
opportunities for skills development and
job
creation the report provides details of
each of the 10 projects currently in the
program and an update on progress there
are no decisions to be made tonight the
purpose of this report is to set out
publicly some of the issues that we will
need to address in due
course this funding represents a
significant step up in the scale of the
council's Regeneration Capital program
at the time of the bid submissions and
funding Awards the council was not
adequately resourced to deliver a
program at this scale therefore it has
been essential for the council to employ
additional project management officers
and appoint construction design teams to
deliver the program as everybody knows
we've also experienced a period of high
inflation and though reasonable
assumptions were made about inflation we
could not have anticipated the 20 to 30%
increases in construction costs that
we've actually seen and this is common
across the whole of the national
leveling up program at the time of the
central government bidding rounds many
projects submitted for funding across
the national bidding program we only at
concept stage with only high level
projections of costs and timelines
considerable work has been completed to
develop the original program Concepts
into deliverable projects with updated
costs and delivery timelines and we've
also learned more about the likely
viability of some of the projects
proposed it's not just a question of
whether the initial investment is
possible possible within the funding
envelope provided but in some cases
whether the proposed use would be
achievable or
sustainable in this respects I've
arranged to meet the thanet fisherman's
Association to ensure that I understand
at firsthand their position on that
project and how we can best support
them I recently had the opportunity to
visit the clock house which has now
returned to council control and I'm
confident from talking to
representatives of the Ramsgate Heritage
regeneration trust and the Ramsgate
society as as well as our officers and
project leads that we're not only going
to be able to safeguard the historic
building but also provide something
really special in it and I know from
speaking regularly to the staff at the
new inton community center how positive
they are about the works planned there
I've also seen firsthand the potential
of 5A Broad
Street we're working through the Royal
Institute of architecture's Design
stages for each project this provides a
much improved understanding of the
design and
outcomes project time lines and the
estimated cost this work is continuing
and importantly we have commissioned a
detailed condition survey and costed
schedule of works for the port
infrastructure project we know that the
cost of this project will exceed the
original Grant allocation and the
outcome of this work will provide much
gler clarity about these costs it will
also be aligned with our process to
appoint an operator in order to ensure
that major investment is only made to
meet the demand which we remain
confident now
exists we will also expl other options
to fund the port infrastructure and are
already engaging with government on a
strategic level in view of the pressures
on DOA and its Motorway access
Corridor overall inflation has put
pressure on the affordability of the
fall program but most projects remain
deliverable and where they may not be
that is not just about the upfront cost
it's inevitable that we will have to
make some difficult decisions about the
final program over the coming months and
use the flexibility provided to the
council as part of the simplification
part pathway pilot to switch funds
between projects where this is necessary
we've already committed to not moving
funds from Margate to Ramsgate or from
Ramsgate to Margate but within each Town
adjustments will be required at this
stage cabinet is simply asked to note
the progress made and challenges which
have emerged the report will also
progress onto the overview and scrutiny
panel so that it can be further
discussed importantly each individual
project will be considered by the
overview and scrutiny panel and cabinet
before being approved once complete
information about project design
outcomes timelines and costs are known I
moved the recommendations um as set out
in the
[Applause]
report I've got to
remember I'm sure I've got councelor
Austin and counselor
Davis just got to find the right bit of
paper that written there I'm going to
call on councelor
ay thank you Luda um I wanted to say
that we're very pleased in our corner of
the chamber to see the detailed report
which obviously as as scrutiny members
some of us have been asking for for some
time we found the briefing very useful
the other week and we're grateful to
officers and members for their hard work
on this we're encouraged by the positive
progress on many of the
projects we are getting a lot of push
back from residents about the ferry
operation and about money being done
diverted into the ferry operation from
other areas and one of the things that
we would find helpful would be to see a
separation of the costs of our providing
the port and harbor that we are statut
required to provide on the one hand and
the costs of a potential Ferry operation
on the other and it may be that that's
in the documentation but I'm not aware
of it if it is so I haven't spotted it
it would be really helpful to have that
and it would be really helpful to be
able to explain that to Residents
because people are concerned that what
they see as projects that will benefit
them straightforwardly in Ramsgate as
residents and as
businesses uh like the smack boys
project for example are potentially
being dropped in favor of work on a
ferry which may not happen and obviously
ramate residents are a bit cynical about
Ferry having had previous experience in
this area um I'm pleased to see that
we're still considering possibilities
for the smack boys Building because
personally it's one of my favorite
buildings in Ramsgate and there's many
many beautiful buildings in Ramsgate so
it's got quite a lot of competition uh
but we are concerned that if blueberry
homes who sold their Flats along the
seafront so quickly haven't been able to
provide a find a hotel provider to
complete their site whether we'll
actually manage to find somebody who is
willing to invest in the smack boys
building we do hope they are because
it's it's definitely in need of uh
support and refurbishment and we'd like
to see it used um better than it is at
the moment but um the the separation of
that money would be our particular
concern and it would be really helpful
if we could have a bit more information
on that thank
you well in a minute I'll throw that to
Mr H because I'm I'm sure he's desperate
to speak about it um but I I I
absolutely understand that you can
interpret this report as um money being
moved from two of the projects in the
harbor um to support um the port as I
said there's no decision being taken
here we haven't made that decision what
we've tried to do is set out a
reasonable worst case scenario um around
the port
infrastructure um and to make clear that
we're not going to fall into the Trap of
committing very large sums of money to a
project which won't actually deliver
anything because nobody wants to come
and use it and I absolutely understand
the skepticism that surrounded um the
port previously but the world has
changed um and the situation and the
demand for the port of Ramsgate is
different now um I'm confident about
that the previous administration was
confident about that um that doesn't
mean to say that we will spend any
amount of money um in order to make the
port work clearly we won't do that we
will look at the uh benefits and the
merits for Ramsgate and thanet and for
the country as a whole because I think
we all recognize that there is a a
problem at DOA um but this is not the
case that the projects which are we're
struggling to take forward and in the
case of um smack boys not able to take
forward in the way that we envisaged are
being downgraded or downsized in order
to move money um to the port that's not
what has happened or is is happening um
there are challenges with those projects
uh and we have to recognize those
challenges so um as I say no decisions
tonight we're informing people I'm glad
you like the information um I hope we're
going be able to do something similar
for for Margate and have some good news
in that as well um and I'll bring in Mr
Humber to talk about um splitting out
the costs as you put
it yeah thank you leader um so in terms
of the process and and what we're going
through um at the moment and what the
report refers to and it mentions a date
of um June for having more um
information on the cost and that's
because we're currently tendering for
some more survey work and that will um
provide us with more detail on uh
estimate of the cost of the works and I
think at that time we will share that uh
you know back via um you know a report
to to cabinet uh to be clear about what
we're talking about for the for the cost
of the works is that is that sorry
councelor is that what you're asking for
specifically in when you when you talk
about the costs for the um for the the
works for the ferry because that that's
the works to the moing spine the two
births and also the landside
infrastructure those those are that
that's what we're talking about I think
isn't it rather than rather than the
other statutory Harbor Authority Parts
mayor leader um the we would I was
asking about what what is it we are
statut obliged to provide because we
have a Port Harbor and what costs might
we be incurring for a ferry service and
to try to separate those out because
those are things that residents are are
concerned to understand the the
difference between the
two okay um
so the port as it currently stands has
uh birth infrastructure the the you know
there's there's the winon burst the the
two roro burst and and bth 4 five for
Aggregates um as a harbor Authority
where where whatever um services that we
provide for the customers for the type
of Port it is then we must maintain
those and there's costs associated with
that um that you know it depends on the
business of the port we're not for
example not the container Port so we
don't have the facilities for that so if
we have the facilities and we're using
them then we we there's cost yes so that
EXA exactly that so you know it's put
under the Lu project we are proposing to
make the port ready again with modern
facilities for roro um you roll on
rolloff uh services so that is the
subject of that survey work on those
facilities to bring those to a um you
know a modern good standard for uh a
period of time while we offer a port
concession um so they the cost that we
will share um when we've got those later
on this
year 20.1
councel thank you leer
um where to begin the amount of
questions this report raises uh we're
not going to get through tonight but
I've got several issues I'd like to uh
perhaps try and get to the bottom of and
to highlight to Cabinet
um
the the issues are becoming conflated
here because we've got the issue of what
of whether the port works and many of us
have got a view on
that however let's assume that these
expressions of Interest are valid etc
etc why are we conflating for example
births 2 and three with leveling up
projects birth two and three exist and
I've got a very real question I think
every single person on this cabinet
should be asking and that's why do they
need any anything doing to them when
they had 1.6 million spent on three
emergency decisions in
20156 1.6 million emergency decisions
that bypass scrutiny we are now being
asked to believe that they need
substantial money spending on them and
£100,000 is being spent on the tender to
create that report in addition I'd like
to point out that in June 22 a further
report was conducted into the condition
of birth to which has never been
published despite us asking for it there
is something very a miss here either
incompetence or something very wrong 1.6
million and we're now being asked to to
look at spending more where's that money
coming from if it comes from the
leveling up fund that's there to provide
leveling up benefits to the community
not to subsidize other people's errors
or to T up what's not being used bar in
mind that you can't get vessels in at
the current debt because it's not
dredged properly let's then move on from
that cuz there are very serious
questions there however there is um also
contradiction in these reports about who
is responsible for maintenance we've
just had the debacle of 2 and a half
million nearly being wasted on birth and
I'm going to say birth for because you
can't actually get on to birth five cuz
it's a beach that debacle dragged on for
3 years is still subject to
investigation from Grant thornson the
external Auditors and here we are
plowing straight down the same route
again throwing money after money at
births that by the way birth three has
not been used and maybe someone can
answer is it currently commissioned or
not because it seems not so having had a
million pounds there about spent on it
six years ago it now needs another
Fortune don't believe it I do not
believe it and the residents do not
believe it so we need some robust ANS to
is some robust questions here and I'm
sorry to be throwing this at you but
these are vital points with regard to
the smack boys home I asked uh I believe
it was ons could we please guarantee
that the building would be preserved and
protected because of its intrinsic value
within the harbor estate and the fact
it's grade two star listed I was told
that could only happen because there has
to be some sort of yield or outcome from
the application of leveling up funds
firstly we need then to be creative and
stop relying on rehashes of old projects
because this beu hotel has come up three
times now with different funding
applications it was proven about five or
six years ago as being eyewash and yet
we're supposed to believe that it was
cobbled together hastily for the
leveling up bid not so so leveling up
well we need some robust answers and we
need to know what is leveling up because
I'm going to ask you the question is it
appropriate use of leveling up money to
subsidize organization like border force
and their infrastructure I do not
believe it to be appropriate use of the
leveling up money and I think the whole
thing needs looking at as to how this
regeneration partnership board is going
to conduct itself and also you know what
were you going to deliver for 3.1
million or 6 million whatever the
original budget was we're expected now
to believe that 10 million plus 25%
leeway
25% in a commercial environment if I ask
for 25% way on a budget that I was
putting in for I'd be laughed out the
door but let's look at it potentially
122 million now to deliver what was
supposedly 6 million something isn't
adding up here and it's the same old
story as we've had on births four and
five and this P all the way through
there are alternative uses for that 32
Acres that could be yielding vast sums
of money jobs and opportunity to the
community and plowing down a row row row
row unaccompanied Freight is not it
thank
you thank you councelor Davis
um just to deal with your point about 10
million 12 A5 million um the truth is we
don't know what the cost of um getting
the infrastructure into an appropriate
state to receive a ferry service is and
that's why we're doing the work we put
that figure out there because that's our
best estimate um we're not saying that
we're going to find 10 million or 12 A2
million we've said we think that's what
it looks like um I was near in 20156 so
I will have to rely on Mr Humber to tell
us um about the works that were carried
out to the births um so I'll hand over
to
him thank you leader um yeah and thank
you counselor for the questions and I've
I've um sort of made a few notes as you
as you went through those so I'll try
and um briefly answer uh each each point
of as you've made it so the first thing
I think was the uh birth 2 three and why
um why we're now revisiting that but um
as you point out it's 2016 so it's it's
very nearly eight years ago um so those
Works were done those refurbishment
works and there is a need to do more
work and that's that's you know it's
some time ago some time ago now um you
mentioned about uh whether uh they're in
commission or not birth two is in birth
two is in commission and and being used
birth three was decommissioned uh from
use in
2019 um and um this work is proposed to
bring it back into back into commission
um you're you're right that uh in 2022
there was a condition report undertaken
on the burth that was um very much uh
from the Viewpoint of scoping so that
has helped us with the um quite complex
tender that we've put out now for the um
for the design for the um survey and
design work which is above water below
water and that um that initial survey
which is which forms part of the tender
pack and it's intended to form part of
the tender pack which has gone out now
um and and is currently live as a as a
tender um dredging you mentioned and um
yes you're uh correct in that we the
port is fairly sh I.E um there is quite
a lot of deposited material and but
that's recognized in the 2425 budget and
there's further uh there's an increase
in the budget in the 24 in the draft
2425 budget for the port for maintenance
dredging because of that so that we'll
be able to achieve more dredging next
year um as a as a result of that
um just picking sticking on on the on
the port item the um mentioned that
subsidizing border force of course
border Force um facilities are Trader
provided so it's the statutary harbor
Authority that must provide those
facilities and um and the board of force
provide the Staffing for that and the um
staty Harbor Authority provide the
facilities so that's set out in uh in in
act in Statute in the Immigration Act um
I think if there's any anything else
happy to cover
that I think um Mr car Michael wishes to
say something just a point a point on um
the reference to birth 45 and Grant
Thornton's interest in it I don't
believe there is any interest uh anymore
Matt if you'd like to confirm um what
happened on that was that there was a
recommendation from the Independent
monitoring officer to conduct a review
into what happened on birth 45 uh Chris
blundel and I commissioned in the
internal Auditors to do that review and
we reported that to cabinet and to
Council in March of last year and the
conclusion was it wasn't to be honest uh
the council's finest hour but there were
a number of recommendations with all of
which we accepted to do with project
management improvements and we're
working through those now thank you
leader thank you and I think I've got
Council app
PE thank you chair there I was worried
that you done forgotten about me so
there we are
um um I'd like to thank officers for for
bringing this report forward I mean it's
it's quite an extensive document and I'm
sure this has taken quite a lot of time
and equally as well as has been
mentioned I think by councelor Austin
the members briefing that was held last
week admittedly I know that it was short
notice and that has been um admitted by
officers in in the planning of that but
I think it was really important to have
that members briefing because it's
important that all councilors understand
not just the implications for the
leveling up funds but but everything and
and the cost pressures pressures that
are coming into this so I appreciate
that and I appreciate briefings um from
officers and from the shadow cabinet in
relation to this I do have a few
questions um in relation to a few parts
of the report and I appreciate that
there are cost pressures that are coming
in with a lot of uh trying to deliver
with this leveling up fund those risks
and some of those risks were present
maybe not as evident to us when we were
in control of the council considering
the level of inflation that we're
experiencing now um but we were still
aware of um of certain risks at the time
I just have a few questions in that
particularly to do with uh the fishing
facilities so it's been stated in the
report that uh there was engagement in
Autumn of last year and that uh thanet
Fisher Fisheries Association or
Fisherman's Association um had expressed
that they they don't want the facility
to to come forward my question is and I
appreciate that there probably been
meetings going backs and forwards and I
welc commit leader that you're going to
be meeting with uh the TFA and I think
that's really important to hear it from
them as well but my question is is that
have we had confirmation from them from
the the Ramsgate fisherman in writing
that they don't want to bring forward
uh the processing facility I think it's
really important if as the report states
that uh the fishing industry is in a I
hope a temporary decline at the moment
in Ramsgate I think that if it is then
surely this is the time when if there is
funding available from the 11 up fund we
need to be trying to support them as
much as possible whether that be
delivering the entire facility or an
aspect of it or you know move in the um
the moin and and all of that I think
it's it's this probably isn't the time
for us to then put our hands up and go
well if it's in Decline then there's not
much that we can do so my question is
that have we had that confirmation in
writing because it's all fine us having
meetings with them but I think going
forward if that is something that then
isn't going to be delivered I think we
really need to make sure that that
that's as as water tie as it is as it
needs to be the other questions that I
have is that particularly in relation to
uh the funding or the funding or
projected funding that's needed uh for
improvements to the port yes
um you'll be surprised to hear uh not
compared to the the applicate the sorry
the agenda on uh the potential for EG
gypsian traveler site and shut down Road
I am going to concede that yes it was
the previous administration that put
forward the report um and accepted um
the report to open up the tender process
for an operator on the port um I stand
by that decision I think it's really
important that residents and us as a
council have Clarity on what potential
operators and what could be done with
the port I think it's not fair for us to
keep kind of going around in circles and
maintaining an asset if it's not then
necessarily generating an income for the
council or for the betterment of
residents so I think that's really
important I just want to be clear on
that my only question is is
that if an operator is secured for the
port a suitable operator one that can
bring I'm not saying that we agree to
just anything for the sake of it but one
that can bring benefits to the area
surely it's important that we wait until
we understand what it is that that
operator wants to do in the port because
I appreciate that one operator may want
to focus on restoring roro services and
another operator may want to focus on uh
bringing in and out and freight and and
you know I know there's a lot of
interesting ideas banded around that so
surely for the time being we should
completely wait and I know that it does
reference this in the report but I just
want confirmation from cabinet tonight
that we will absolutely wait until
there's an idea of whether there's suit
operator for the port but what I would
like to propose is that we wait until we
have secured an operator so that we
ensure that we know what their needs are
so that we're not committing uh any any
funding from the leveling up fund that's
allocated for something else um before
we we understand that my final question
is and apologies I'm not trying to put
officers on the spot but it's been
referenced in the report that there
isn't any suitable funding elsewhere
from Council budgets to allow for uh
this extra spend that needs to be done
on the report and my question is that is
there any is there any capacity for us
to apply to the public loans board for
an asset such as this if it does need
this much work for us to to put forward
for that now if there isn't then that's
absolutely fine but I thought that I'd
I'd ask thank you well yeah thank you
councilor p and I think that um it's
fair to say that um when we were in
opposition we supported the proposal
that was brought forward and obviously
we brought forward the the leveling up
proposals in the first place so I think
we've always been on the same page as
regards the poll um and I think that
that is drawn of the experience
respective experience of former
councelor Ashby and myself in terms of
the interest in in using the port um
nothing IDE logical about it I think
that we believe it we believe it can
work um I think in terms of of borrowing
money and I know um Mr s will be
chomping up the bit to get involved the
trouble with borrowing money is that
their revenue cost to repaying it um and
probably we don't have scope in our um
Revenue budget to um repay significant
loans for Port
infrastructure I I I'll let you come in
in a minute Mr
s
um I don't think there's any proposal to
spend leveling up money that's allocated
to anything else um until we um are
clear where we're going in respect of um
the pool infrastructure and absolutely
we want to hear what what people want to
do and the two process two processes
need to be aligned and I'm relying on Mr
Humber to do that and uh I know that
certainly his intention and in respect
to the Fisher the Fishers um yeah I do
want to go and hear from them myself
unfortunately Miss ASI is not here this
evening she might be able to answer your
question about whether we've got
something in writing I'm not going to
ask other officers about that um but I
think it's absolutely important that we
support the fishing fleet in Ramsgate I
understand that there are eight boats
operating um if we're going to build if
we're going to build them A4 million
pound facility that's quite um a big
responsibility for them to meet the
running cost of um but if we can't do
that and we probably can't because they
probably can't sustain it um we do need
to talk to them about how we can support
them and try and make sure that we don't
end up with no fishing fleet in Ramsgate
because that would be a very sad day and
I don't think any of us want to see that
um there is some funds in the leveling
up that we can use use to support the
fishes and we need to find out how we
can best do that by having further
conversations but I know there's a lot
of work already been done by officers um
and it's important that we do that and
now I'm going to let Mr Sanam
speak thank you chair it's not that we
can't approach the Public Works loan
board to borrow money it's that it's
kind of The Perfect Storm at the moment
with regards to borrowing is the the
interest rates are the worst that
they've been for probably the last 10 15
years in terms of borrowing so the anti
ipated Revenue cost associated with
borrowing even if it's a 2 and A5
million pound Gap is about £400,000
perom that we would need to find is
savings to facilitate that because
that's not based anywhere and obviously
that's on 2 and a half million if it
goes up from there that increases so we
just haven't got the impact because when
you look at 25 26 26 27 which is when
the funding would be uh required um the
budget proposal in terms of the mtfs
already shows that there's potential
savings requirement in that year and we
would just be adding to that
position
and I think um it's worth saying that we
would look to see if there's uh
opportunity to recover some of the costs
of this work through the uh contract
with the operator but what we didn't
want to say is that we're attributing a
chunk of these costs to the operator up
front because we need to have a an open
process and understand what it is people
want to do at the Port um and what they
can afford to um support in terms of the
infrastructure so uh members I'm not
sure that I um actually asked for a
second on this item that councilor Yates
has has volunteered um does anybody wish
to say Council Yates yeah I was just we
mentioned the port of do earlier and um
I just thought it' be uh worth
highlighting that there's going to be
some changes to the requirements at do
in October of this year I was actually
with the Kent County Council highways
manager um earlier this afternoon who
responsible for the EU transition and
new rules are being implemented in in
October this year which include
fingerprint and facial
recognition um so I think it's worth
noting the context of this that do is
likely to be uh heavily impacted in with
those rules in October and although this
uh project could take a number of years
um there is concern about do and its
ability to uh to deal with that um and
it's likely that every passenger car
going through is going to have an iPad
brought in to scan your face and do a
fingerprint um and how that's dealt with
on individual cases is very interesting
especially if you're a brickie and your
fingerprints aren't quite uh as uh
visible as others so yeah I think the
context of those new rules uh I just
wanted to mention because it is quite um
seriously being looked at
thanks thank you Council Yates members
any other
comments okay so this is um going to
scrutiny where obviously there will be
further OPP unities to ask questions I
shall remind members of the
recommendations uh one to note the
progress achieved in the delivery of the
approved Ramsgate regeneration programs
to note that further reports will be
received authorizing specific
procurement activities as each
respective project reaches that stage
and setting out the project deliverables
timelines and costs three note the
proposed monitoring and Reporting
Arrangements set out in section six four
note the current funding Gap in the
program and five refur this report to
the overview scrutiny panel and
subsequently consider any comments made
by the panel do members agree thank you
and we move on to item 12 which is Dane
Park waste Depo waste um you can have
that one counselor
album how kind chair save the best all
last day
um uh this is uh uh this report to
Cabinet is uh is on an issue that is uh
was particular
concerning and um but it it needs to
come because of the amount of money that
it's cost uh and I just want to go
through um some points there's only 20
of the points so just bear with me
um the head of coastal and public realm
started uh and his rooll in
September the officer was
tasked uh with installing five electric
vehicle charging points at Dame Park
Depot during a site visit to the depot
uh the officer found a large waste large
waste piles where the points uh the
electric charging points would have been
installed uh the waste came from Grounds
Maintenance of Open Spaces across the
district the council was not uh sorry
the council was
storing 2,000
180 tons of waste at the
Depot the depot has what's called a t23
waste exemption
certificate for 60 tons of
waste and this waste must be suitable
for
uh
composting
um the council uh waste
consultant was ask asked to advise on
the waste at the Depot the consultant
confirmed the waste at the Depot
exceeded that that
allowed obviously by the size of
it um further they confirmed the council
was at risk of sanctions being imposed
by the environment
agency the consultant advised that uh
courts can issue substantial fines and
custodial sentences for non-compliance
with waste
activities the corporate management team
agreed the immediate action should be
taken to remove the waste from the site
and dispose of it through a compliant
waste disposal service I was also part
of that decisionmaking
process um an estimated cost of
£225,000 for the work was provided Ed by
uh M which is a company that the council
does a lot of work with due to the
estimated cost of the agreement to
remove the waste was a decision that
officers could enter into without it
having to come to uh
cabinet
um given the urgency of remedying this
issue it was agreed by the section 15
one
officer that the contract could be
entered into with the identified waste
disposal service without the usual
procurement
process works commenced removing all of
the waste in late
November this was completed within a
matter of
weeks officers were then advised that
the final cost of the waste removal was
£275,000
and approval for that is now being
sought officers have put in place
measures that will ensure the depot is
compliant with its t23 waste exemption
certificate going
forward what I can
advise is that um although it's not
within the report but I think it's it's
it should it should be
said um that the
275,000 uh has been taken from the risk
reserves um but what I would also
say is that um should that waste have
been removed over the period of time
that that it was there it would cost
about the same money the same amount of
money that has been used to remove it
and we believe although we're not sure
we have looked at Google Earth and to
see at how this um mound of 200 and tons
of um grass Etc was growing uh We
Believe it' been there for about four
years and
growing
um
so what I would also say is that the
environment agency uh was advised about
this as soon as as soon as
possible and uh we have been contacted
by the environment agency and they have
advised that no risk perspective action
is to be taken by them in relation to
this um I'm confident and and I and I
thank uh the head of service Mr marmo
for uh seeing this sorting it out and
getting things done uh to remove it and
but I would say it is embarrassing for
the
council um and it shouldn't have
happened and the only reason that I can
foresee
that that I can see so not forese I the
only thing that I that I could see with
this uh it was a
time which coincided with this waste
building up was when we never had an
Open Spaces manager looking over the
staff and ensuring the things things
were done and nothing was reported to
anywhere and uh so uh this is an
important matter to ensure that this
doesn't happen again and I and I'm sure
but by a head of service and our
director that uh things have now been
put in place and you can see from the
report
itself um uh uh what the costings are
they've been sep separated out in in the
report and how it's come to that amount
of money so chair um I'm I'm
recommending uh as
follows uh the cabinet approve uh the
cabinet ratify the decision made by the
section 151 officer on the 16th of
November 2024 to enter into a contract
with the estimated value of £225,000
with
mirrors um for the removal of the
disposal of the waste from D Park Depot
uh the cabinets approves the payment of
additional £50,000 based on the final
cost of removal disposal of the way from
Dame Park Depot being £275,000
thank you
chair thank you um councelor Alin um is
there a second councilor ke um and I
will say that I don't think any member
of this Council would think that this
situation which has been uncovered by Mr
Maro was in any way acceptable or
defensible or
appropriate um and we have to be
grateful that Mr Maro um joined us and
was uh alert to the issue that it
created and I think also whereare
that this matter is a consequence of
roles not being filled within the
council positions not being occupied by
officers um over a period of time um it
clearly has gone on for a very long
while I don't think there's any point
pointing fingers at different
administrations um members will be
challenged to understand some of the
environmental regulations I think um but
nevertheless it's it's just not good
enough um and I shall call in councilor
a I'm sure has a similar opinion thank
you absolutely chair thank you uh and
thank you councilor Robin um I wanted to
extend my sympathies to Mr MMO starting
a new role and uh finding this on his
doorstep uh and thank him for his
efforts in in sorting this out I've got
two questions the first one is in view
of the council's climate change
commitments and in view of the small
capacity of the store at uh at Dame Park
are we planning in the future to defay
the costs of the new chipper Etc by
selling compost selling mulch anything
of that kind I know Mr Elma has talked
about uh Gathering up leaves from
various places and composting them Etc
is there a is there a bit of a side
business that we can be doing here
because I'm sure we have residents with
allotments and so on who would be
delighted to purchase those sorts of
items at modest cost and the second
question is from a community perspective
one of the things that has always
happened at DNE Park Depot is that uh
Garden waste from all the various
gardening groups volunteer gardening
groups that we absolutely rely on across
the district um that waste has been
gathered up and taken to D par Depot and
disposed of by the council which it
strikes me as the least that the council
can do will we still have the facility
to do that in future thank you
yeah thank you councelor Austin uh did
take your second Point uh first the
answer that is yes we continue to do
that and we will continue with
that
oh thank you for I couldn't feel it
normally I can feel it in the back of me
neck but uh yes I I will I
will the answer is that currently we
cannot allow any waste to come to the
depot um because we don't have a permit
to allow that to happen um we're
currently working on that permit um it
normally takes about 6 months to 12
months to get that permit so as it
stands at the moment um the staff at the
Depot have been instructed to help um
the volunteer groups and the parish and
town councils that work on our land to
deposit the waste directly to the local
um waste disposal company that we use
and obviously that the council pays for
that um but we we had an instance um
today where I had a phone call where
they had to um ask somebody to not stay
at site and not dispose of their waste
at site and they actually to take the
waste away and then take it to that to
that
company it is intended that in the long
run what we're trying to do is to work
through the various different exemptions
that you can get
plus the permit that will be will take a
lot longer so we we can't say we will
end up in a position where we will be
able to take the waste at the site but
you know we're trying to work towards
that um yeah I'm so pleased that I got
that wrong um and
uh so it just shows you how closely we
work together um
I I I I just assume I I wrongly assume
because we've always done it that we
will
continue to do it um but I I I I Fall to
better I'm just the bloke who's speaking
in a microphone really no um it it is an
important thing and it is important that
that we continue to um ensure that we
look after the volunteers and and and
and we will do that in the best way that
we can and and hopefully it it won't
take 12 months to get another license or
whatever is needed but I certainly will
um the other Point CC was in relation to
climate
change compost and mulch we've got all
the materials there are we using them
and planning on selling
them uh yeah um I no no no no this time
I could feel I could feel the heat from
behind
I had no intention of ask of answering
you thank you chair than thank you
Council Alin um what we're very
conscious of at the moment is that we
don't want to be back in R rule
territory which which um we could we
could be in breach of things so I would
have to take that away and work with the
consultant that we're currently working
with to make sure that we are absolutely
where we need to be um obviously we
would always want to be trying to
maximize the climate emergency and
climate change scenarios so I'll
definitely take that away and have a
look at
it thank you uh councilor
Davis thank you leer I just wanted to
put on the record sincere thanks to Tony
marmo for actually knowing his job
because it seems that you know now we
know it's four years this mck's been
piling up for or DeBry um whilst there
have been periods without open spaces
managers I think that's one of the
Departments that we've got a record for
recruiting more than any others for and
four or five came and went over that
period um I do think we've had a lucky
escape from the sounds of it um and I do
hope and trust that the relevant action
will be taken to
take what what's the word I want um
restorative action with those
responsible because you know I would
imagine they've got a labrador next to
them if they didn't notice four times 60
tons was was something odd um there will
be people in this Authority that have
just allowed this to go on and you know
how many how many other issues do we
have to have we quarter of million PS
it's granted some of that would have
been spent with the disposal of the
waste as has been pointed out but there
are additional cost we've had a lucky
Escape someone's responsible
somewhere
thank you councelor Davis do you want to
reply rep that coun I'm not sure there
was an actual question there to answer
but but what I would say is that that
that tonnage that was taken away it's it
is grass it is so there's no Building
Material there's nothing like like that
and it's is purely it's purely that
which so imagine the size of a mound for
for this and you probably see it from
top of Everest but anyway um
uh I I'm uh that was taken away and is
used as compost very green celor Austin
uh you'll be pleased to to
hear oh well just if you want green you
can't make money let's be favorite no no
no no no no we won't we won't get into
that but anyway thank you
chair okay I mean I think that we have
to recognize that this has
arisen is obviously by definition a
legacy issue and I think that part of
the reason it's Arisen is has has been
the um Senior Management situation
within this Council um in over the past
four years we're not in that place now
I'm very confident about the offices
we've got in place now you know I am
embarrassed for the council that we've
got this item on the agenda this evening
um I think it tells um a poor story but
I am equally confident that we have now
got the people in place um to advise us
properly and deliver for services um in
the proper way and I don't think there's
any point in hunting around for
individuals who are probably no longer
here to blame for what has happened uh